OK.
Uh this is the review
lecture for the first part
of the course, the Ax=b
part of the course.
And the exam will
emphasize chapter three.
Because those are
the --0 chapter
three was about the
rectangular matrices
where we had null spaces and
null spaces of A transpose,
and ranks, and all
the things that
are so clear when the matrix
is square and invertible,
they became things to think
about for rectangular matrices.
So, and vector spaces and
subspaces and above all
those four subspaces.
OK, I'm thinking to
start at least I'll
just look at old exams,
read out questions, write
on the board what
I need to and we
can see what the answers are.
The first one I see is
one I can just read out.
Well, I'll write a little.
Suppose u, v and w are
nonzero vectors in R^7.
What are the possible -- they
span a -- a vector space.
They span a subspace of R^7,
and what are the possible
dimensions?
So that's a
straightforward question,
what are the possible dimensions
of the subspace spanned
by u, v and w?
OK, one, two, or three, right.
One, two or three.
Couldn't be more because
we've only got three vectors,
and couldn't be zero because --
because I told you the
vectors were nonzero.
Otherwise if I allowed the
possibility that those were all
the zero vector -- then the
zero-dimensional subspace would
have been in there.
OK.
Now can I jump to a
more serious question?
OK.
We have a five by three matrix.
And I'm calling it U.
I'm saying it's in echelon form.
And it has three pivots, r=3.
Three pivots.
Ok.
First question what's
the null space?
What's the null
space of this matrix
U, so this matrix is five by
three, and I find it helpful to
just see
visually what five by three
means, what that shape is.
Three columns.
Three columns in U,
then five rows,
three pivots,
and what's the null space?
The null space of U is --
and it asks for a
spec-of course I'm
looking for an answer
that isn't just
the definition of
the null space,
but is the null space of this
matrix, with this information.
And what is it?
It's only the zero vector.
Because we're told
that the rank is three,
so those three columns must be
independent, no combination --
of those columns is the
zero vector except --
so the only thing in this
null space is the zero vector,
and I --
I could even say what that
vector is, zero, columns also?
zero, zero.
That's OK.
So that's what's
in the null space.
All right? let me go on with
-- this question has multiple
parts.
What's the -- oh now it asks you
about a ten by three matrix, B,
which is the matrix U and two U.
It actually -- I would
probably be writing R --
and maybe I should be
writing R here now.
This exam goes back a few
years when I emphasized U more
than R.
Now, what's the echelon
form for that matrix?
So the echelon form,
what's the rank,
Yes. and what's
the echelon form?
Let's suppose this is
in reduced echelon form,
so that I could be
using the letter R.
So I'll ask for the reduced row
echelon form so imagine that
So I'm seeing the same length
in b, three, and also in x.
these are --
U is in reduced row
echelon form but now
I've doubled the
height of the matrix,
So the (x)-s that it multiplies
have three components,
what will happen when
we do row reduction?
What row reduction will
take us to what matrix here?
So you start doing elimination.
You're doing elimination
on single rows.
But of course we're
allowed to think of blocks.
So what, well, what's
the answer look like?
U and z- or R --
let's -- I'll stay with this
letter U but I'm what was
the name of that --2 winning
a million dollars or really
thinking it's in
reduced form, and zero.
OK.
Fine.
Then it asks oh, further,
it asks about this matrix.
U, U, U, and zero.
OK, what's the
echelon form of this?
So it's just like
practice in thinking
through what would
row elimination,
what would row reduction do.
Have I thought this through,
so what -- what are we --
if we start doing elimination,
basically we're going
to subtract these
rows from these --
In the column
space, because I do
know that it can so it's going
to take us to U, U, zero,
and minus U, For example, I'm
going to ask you for a I guess,
right?
But is it a- is
it three by three?
Take the thing all the way to R
-- let's suppose U is really R.
Suppose that we're really going
for the reduced row echelon
doing linear
algebra of course --
but I didn't have
to do the form.
Then would we stop there?
No.
We would clean out, we would
-- we could use this to --
is that right, can I
so I took this row --
these rows away from
these to get there.
Now I take these rows away from
these, so that gives me zero.
There. there?1 And now what
more would I do if I'm really
shooting for R, the
reduced row echelon form?
I would -- then I want
plus ones in the pivot,
so I would multiply through by
minus one to get plus there.
So essentially I'm seeing
reduced row echelon form
there and there, and there's
just one little twist
still to go.
Do you see what that
final twist might be?
It certainly has three rows.
To have if -- if U is in
reduced row echelon form and now
I'm looking at U, U, there's
one little step to take,
this isn't like a big
deal at all, but --
but if I really want this
to be in reduced form,
what would I still --
might I still have to do?
I might have some
zero rows here,
I might have some zero
rows here that strictly
should move to the bottom.
Well, I'm not going to
make a project out of that.
first of all?
OK.
What's the rank of that matrix?
What's the rank
of this matrix C?
Given that I know that the
original U has rank three,
what's the rank of this guy?
Six, right.
That has rank six, I can tell.
What was -- what's the
rank of this B, while --
while we're at on TV for a
few weeks, did you see that,
it?
The rank of B, is
that six or three?
So A is a three by three matrix.
Three is right.
Because we actually got it to
where we could just see three
pivots.
OK, and oh, now
finally this easy one,
what's the dimension be solved
exactly when B is in the column
space, of the null space --
of the null space
of C transpose?
Oh, boy.
OK, so what do I -- if I want
the dimension of a null space,
I want to know the
size of the matrix --
so what's the size
of the matrix C?
It looks like it's
ten by six, is it?
Ten by six, so C is ten by six,
so m is ten, so C has ten rows,
C transpose has ten columns,
so there are ten columns there.
So how many free variables
have I got, once I --
There's quite a few trues,
shall I take a poll,
if I start with the ten
columns in C transpose,
that's the m for the original C.
And what do I subtract off?
Six.
Because we said
that was the rank.
So I'm left with four.
Thanks.
OK.
If b is in the -- and what
would -- what does the exam say
So I think that's
the right answer --
the dimension of the null space
of C transpose would be four.
Right.
OK.
Yeah.
So that's one question, at
least it brought in some --
some of the dimension counts.
OK.
Here's another type of question.
think about, what's the --
what's the shape of the matrix,
I give you an equation,
Ax equals two four two.
And I give you the
complete solution.
And what's its rank?
But I don't give you the matrix.
And another -- there's another
vector, zero, zero, one.
OK.
All right.
My first question is what's
the dimension of the row space?
Of the matrix A?
So the main thing that you
want to get from this question
is that a question
could start this way.
exam, don't just tell me.
Sort of backward way.
so I guess I'm
asking you what is
the column space for this
basis for the null space.
By giving you the answer and
not telling you what the problem
homework, so I was watching
it, so there were three --
the is.
But we can get a
lot of information,
and sometimes we can
get complete information
about that matrix A.
OK.
So what's the dimension
of the row space of A?
What's the rank?
Tell me about what's the size
of the matrix, yeah, just --
These are the things
we want to matrix b
and I'll answer them
without multiplying it out.2
Its rank -- tell me something
about its null space,
I heard the right
answer for the rank,
the rank is one in this case.
Why?
Because the dimension
of the null space,
so the dimension of this
instant?3 the null space of A
is from knowing that that's the
complete solution, it's two.
I'm seeing two vectors
here, and they're
independent in the
null space of A,
because they have to be in the
OK, which -- did
you watch that quiz,
there was a quiz program null
space of A if I'm allowed
to throw into the solution
any amount of those vectors,
that tells me that's the
null space part then.
So the dimension of the null
space is two, and then I --
of course I know the dimensions
of all the -- four subspaces.
Now actually it asks
what's the matrix?
Well, what's the
matrix in this case?
Do we want to -- shall I
try to figure that out?
Sure.
Let's -- you'd like
me to do it, OK.
Well, what's the ----
I actually say in this in the
So what about the matrix,
or let me at least start it,
OK.
If A times this x
gives two, four, two,
what does that tell
me about the matrix A?
If A times that x solves that
equation then it tells me that
the first column is --
the first column of A is
-- one, two, one, right.
The first column of A
has to be one, two, one,
because if I
multiply by x, that's
going to multiply just
matrix? the first column,
and give me two, four, two.
And then I've got two
more columns to find,
and what information have
I got to find them with?
A basis for the null space.
I've got the null space.
So the fact that this
is in the null space,
what does that tell So what
is if b has the form --
so I guess I'm asking
what's me about the matrix?
A matrix that has zero,
zero, one in its null space?
That tells me that the last
column of the matrix is zeroes.
so how many think true?
Because this is
in the null space,
the last column has to be
When could it be solved? zeroes.
And because this is in
the null space, what's
the second column?
Well, this in the
null space means
that if I multiply
A by that vector
I must be getting zeroes, so I
think that better be minus one,
minus two, and minus one.
OK.
That's a type of question
that just brings out
the information that's in
that complete solution.
And then actually I go on to
ask what vectors -- for what
OK. vectors B can
Ax=b be solved?
Ax=b can be solved if what --
so I'm looking for a condition
Definitely not. on b,
if any. interesting --
the novel point was there
were three ways that
Can it be solved for
every right-hand side b?
No.
And the answer is --
yes or no --
right.
solvable?
the column space of this
matrix, and what is it?
It's so the column space of
that matrix is all multiples b
Can you tell me something --
so I'll ask questions
about this --
b is a multiple
of one, two, one.
Right?
I can solve the thing if it's
a multiple of one, two, one,
and of course sure enough --
yeah, that was a multiple
of one, two, one,
and so I had a solution.
So this is a case where
we've got lots of null space.
Let me just recall rank is
big, don't forget those cases,
don't forget the other cases
when r is as big as it can be,
OK. r equal m or r equal n.
Those are -- we had a full
lecture on that, the full rank,
full lecture, and important
-- important case.
I gave you every chance
to think about that.
OK.
I'll just move on.
I think this is the
best type of review.
So I'm going to
solve Bx equals zero.
It's just brings
these ideas out.
Apologies to the camera while
I recover glasses and exam.
OK.
How about a few true-false ones?
Actually there won't be
a true-false on the quiz.
But it gives us a
moment of quick review.
True or false, how do
you feel about it at
Here's one.
If the null space --
I have a square matrix.
If its null space is
just the zero vector,
what about the null
space of A transpose?
If the null space of A
is just the zero vector,
and the matrix is
square, what do I
know about the null
space of A transpose?
Also the zero vector.
Good.
And that's a very
very important fact.
OK.
How about this?
These -- look at the space
of five by five matrices
as a vector space.
So it's actually a
twenty-five-dimensional vector
space.
All five by five matrices.
Look at the invertible matrices.
Do they form a subspace?
So I have this five by --
a space of all five by five
matrices.
I can add them, I can
multiply by numbers.
But now I narrow down
to the invertible ones.
And I ask are they a subspace?
And you -- your answer is --
quiet, but nevertheless
definite, no.
Right?
Because if I add two invertible
matrices I have no idea if the
No. answer is invertible.
If I multiply that
invertible -- well,
it doesn't even have
the zero matrix in it,
it couldn't be a subspace.
I have to be able to
multiply by zero --
and stay in my subspace, and the
invertible ones wouldn't work.
Well, the singular ones
wouldn't work either.
They have zero -- the zero
matrix is in the singular
matrices, but if I add two
singular matrices I don't know
if the answer is
singular or not.
OK.
So another true-false.
If b squared equals
zero then b equals zero.
columns then the
question is does Ax=b,
is it always True or false?
If b squared equals zero, true,
false? you could get help,
right --
b squared equals zero, b has to
be a square -- square matrix,
so that I can
multiply it by itself,
does that imply that B is zero?
Are there matrices whose square
could be the zero matrix?
Yes or no?
Yes there are.
There are matrices whose
square is the zero matrix.
So this statement is false.
If b squared is zero, we
don't know that b is zero.
For example -- the best
example is that matrix.
That matrix is a
dangerous matrix.
It will come up in later parts
of this course as an example
of what can go wrong.
And here is a real
simple -- so this --
so if I square that without
doing the multiplication
and finding the
matrix b. matrix,
I do get the zero
matrix,and it shows --
OK.
A system of m
equations in m unknowns
is solvable for
every right-hand side
if the columns are independent.
So can I say that again, I'm --
I'll write it down then
OK.
for short.
m by m matrix independent
So give me a basis for --
for the null space of B.
Let's see.
but you could only
use each way once,
so you couldn't like
use them all the time.
So remember that?
You could -- so you
could poll the audience,
and that was a very --
that was a hundred
percent successful way,
so I'll poll the
audience on this.
If the other possibility --
another possibility you could
call your friend, right,
or he's your friend until he
gives you the wrong answer,
which --
that turned out subspaces,
then A is some multiple of B.
to be very unreliable,
you know, you'd
call up your
brother or something
and ask him for the capital
of whatever, Bosnia.
What does he know,
he makes some guess,
So what -- I would just take
extreme cases if it was me,
matrix, independent columns,
is Ax=b always solvable?
Maybe just hands up for that?
A few.
And who says no?
Oh, gosh, this audience
is not reliable.
Fifty fifty.
I guess I'd say, I'd vote yes.
Because independent
columns, that
means that the rank
is the full size m,
I have a matrix of rank m.
That means it's --
I mean it's square, so
it's an invertible matrix,
and nothing could go wrong.
Yes.
So that's the good case and
we always expect it in chapter
two, but of course
chapter three is --
only one of the possibilities.
OK.
Let me move on to another
question from an old quiz.
OK.
Let's see.
I'm going to give you a matrix,
but I'm going to give it to you
OK.
as a product of a
couple of matrices,
one, one, zero, zero,
one, zero, one, zero, one,
times another matrix, one, zero,
I would like to ask you
questions about that matrix
minus one, two, zero, one,
one, minus one, and all zeroes.
OK.
Let's see, what
dimension I in --
the null space of B
is a subspace of R.
What size vectors
I looking for here?
Because if we don't
know the size,
we aren't going to find
it, right? the null --
this matrix is three
by four obviously.
So if we're looking for the null
space we're looking for those
vectors x in R^4.
OK.
So the null space of B is
certainly a subspace of R^4.
What do you think
its dimension is?
Of course once we
find the basis we
would know the dimension
immediately, but let's
stop first, what's the
rank of this matrix B?
Let's see, what -- is
that matrix invertible,
that square one there?
Let's say sure, I
think it is, yes,
that matrix B looks invertible.
Is that pretty clear?
Yeah.
So I've gone wrong in
this course already,
but I'll still hope that
that matrix is invertible.
Yeah, yeah, because if I look
for a combination of those
three columns -- well, I
couldn't use this middle column
because it would have a one
and in a position that I --
column is otherwise all zero,
so a combination that gives zero
can't give us that problem, and
then the other two are clearly
independent sets -- so
that matrix is invertible.
Later we could take a
determinant or other things.
OK.
What's the setup?
If I have an invertible matrix,
a nice invertible square
matrix, times this guy,
times this second factor,
and I'm looking
for the null space,
does this have any effect?
Is the null -- so what I'm
asking is is the null space
of B the same as the null
space of just this part?
I think so.
If Bx is zero, then
multiplying by that guy
I'll still have zero.
But also if this times
some x give zero,
I could always multiply on the
left by the inverse of that,
because it is invertible,
and I would discover
that this kind of Bx is zero.
You want me to write
some of that down --
if I have a product
here, C times --
times D, say, and
if C is invertible,
the null space of CD,
well, it will the same
as the null space of D.
If C is invertible.
Multiplying by an invertible
matrix on the left
can't change the null space.
OK.
So basically I'm asking you
for the null space of this.
so when do I know -- well, I
would say suppose the matrix
I don't have to do
the multiplication
because I have C is invertible.
That first factor
C is invertible.
It's not going to
change the null space.
OK.
So can we just write down a
basis now for the null space?
So what's the basis for the
null space of -- of that?
So basis for the null space
I'm looking for the two --
there are two pivot
columns obviously.
It clearly has rank two.
If -- so true or false, if
A and B have the same four
I'm looking for the
two special solutions.
They'll come from the
third and the fourth.
The free variables.
OK. so if the third
free variable is a one,
then I think probably I
need a minus one there
and a one there, it looks like.
Do you agree that if I then do
that multiplication I'll get
zero?
And if I have one in the
fourth variable, then
maybe I need a one in the second
variable and maybe a minus two
in the third.
So I just reasoned that through
and then if I look back I see
sure enough that the free
variable part that I sometimes
call F, that up --
that two by two corner,
is sitting here with
all its signs reversed.
So that's -- here
I'm seeing minus F,
and here I'm seeing the identity
in the null space matrix.
OK, so that's the null space.
Another question is solve
Bx equal one, zero, one.
OK.
So that's one question, now
solve complete solutions.
To Bx equal one, zero, one.
OK.
Yeah, so I guess I'm
seeing if I wanted
to get one, zero, one - What's
our particular solution?
So I'm looking for a
particular solution
and then the null space
part.
OK.
I-- actually the
first column of B,
so what's the first
column of our matrix B?
It's the vector one, zero, one.
The first column of
our matrix agrees
with the right-hand side.
So I guess I'm
thinking x particular
plus x null space will be
the particular solution,
since the first column of B is
exactly right, that's great.
And then I have C times
that first null space vector
and D times the other
null space vector.
Right?
The two -- the null space
part of the solution,
as always has the
arbitrary constants,
the particular solution doesn't
have any arbitrary constants,
it's one particular solution,
and in this case it'll --
that one would do.
OK.
Fine.
so those are questions
taken from old quizzes,
any questions coming to mind?
Yeah.
Q: value.
OK.
Well, so that
particular x particular,
it says that let's see,
when I multiply by this guy,
I'm going to get the
first column of B.
That -- if that's a
solution, I multiply B,
B times this x will be
the first column of B,
and so I'm saying that the first
column of this B agrees with
the right-hand side.
So I'm saying that look at the
first column of that matrix B.
If you do the
multiplication, it's --
so what's the first
column of that matrix?
Is that how you do
that multiplication?
I multiply that matrix
by that first column.
And it picks out one, zero, one.
So the first column
of B is exactly that.
And therefore a particular
solution will be this guy.
So I'll repeat that question.
Yeah.
OK.
Yes.
Q: particular solution.
Any of the solutions can
be the particular one
that we pick out.
So like this plus -- plus this
would be another particular
OK.
solution.
It would be another solution.
The particular is just
telling us only take one.
But it's not telling us
which one we have to take.
We take the most convenient one.
I guess in this -- in this
problem that was that one.
Good.
Other questions?
Yes.
And this pattern
of particular plus
null space, of course, that's
going throughout mathematics
of linear systems.
We're really doing mathematics
of linear systems here.
Our systems are discrete and
they're finite-dimensional --
and so it's linear algebra, but
this particular plus null space
goes -- that doesn't depend
on having finite matrices --
that spreads much --
that spreads everywhere.
OK, I'm going to just
like to encourage
you to take problems
out of the book,
let me do the same myself.
OK well here's some
easy true or falses.
I don't know why the
author put these in here.
OK.
If m=n, then the row space
equals the column space.
is invertible -- suppose
A is an invertible
So these are true or falses.
If m equals n, so that
means the matrix is square,
then the row space
equals the column space?
False, good.
Good, what is equal there?
What can I say is
equal, if M -- well,
yeah.
Yeah it -- so that's
definitely false --
the row space and
the column space,
and this matrix is like always
a good example to consider.
So there's a square
matrix but it's row
space is the multiples
of zero, one,
and its column space is
the multiples of one, zero.
Very different.
The row space and
the column space
are totally different
for that matrix.
Now of course if the
matrix was symmetric,
well, then clearly the row
space equals the column space.
OK.
How about this question?
The matrices A and minus A
share the same four subspaces?
Do the matrices A and minus
A have the same column space,
do they have the
same null space,
do they have the same row
space?
What's the answer on that?
Yes or no.
Yes.
Good.
OK.
How about this?
If A and B have the
same four subspaces,
then A is a multiple of B.
If -- suppose those
subspaces are the same.
Then is A a multiple of B?
OK.
How how do you answer
a question like that?
Of course if you want to
answer it yes, then I would --
then they'd have to
think of a reason why.
If you want to answer no
way, then you would --
and I would sort of like
first I would try to think no,
I would say can I come up with
an example where it isn't true?
Let me repeat the question.
And then write the answer.
matrix, then what --
suppose it's six by
six invertible matrix,
then what's its row space, and
its column space is all of R^6,
and the null space, and the null
space of A transpose would be
the zero vector.
So every invertible matrix
is going to give that answer.
If I have a six by
six invertible matrix,
I know what those subspaces are.
Heck, that was back
in chapter two,
when I didn't even know
what subspaces were.
The row space and column space
are both all six-dimensional
space -- the whole space,
and the rank is six,
in other words, and the null
spaces have zero dimension.
So do you see now the answer?
So A and B could be.
So A and B could be for example
any -- so I'm going to say
false.
Because A and B for example --
So an example: A and B any
invertible six by six, six
by six.
So those would have
the same four subspaces
but they wouldn't be the same.
Of course th- there should be
something about those matrices
that would be the same.
It's sort of a natural
problem, so now actually we're
getting to a math question.
The answer is this is not true.
One matrix doesn't have to
be a multiple of the other.
But there must be
something that's true.
And that would be sort of like
a natural question to ask.
If they have the same
subspaces, same four subspaces,
then what -- what could you --
instinct wasn't
necessarily right.
But I hope you now see that
the correct answer is false.
And then you might think
OK, well, they certainly
do have the same rank.
But do -- obviously if they
have the same four subspaces,
they have the same rank.
I might say if
they have the well,
I could extend that question and
think about other possibilities
and finally come up with
something that was true.
But I won't press that one.
Let me keep going with
practice questions.
And these practice questions
are quite appropriate I
think for the exam.
OK.
let's see.
If I exchange two rows of A
which subspaces stay the same?
So I'm trying to
take out questions
that we can answer without you
know we can answer quickly.
If I have a matrix A, and I
exchange two of its rows, which
subspaces stay the same?
The row space does
stay the same.
And the null space
stays the same.
Good.
Correct.
Column space would
be a wrong answer.
OK.
all right, here's a question.
Oh, this leads into
the next chapter.
Why can the vector
one, two, three not
be a row and also
in the null space?
Fitting we close
with this question.
Close is -- so V
equal this one, two,
three can't be in the null space
of a matrix and the row space.
And my question is why not?
Why not?
So this is a
question that we can
because it's sort of asked
in a straightforward way,
we can figure out an answer.
Well, actually yeah --
I'll even pin it down, it
can't be in the null space --
and be a row.
I'll even pin it down further.
Ask it to be a row of A.
Why not?
So I'm -- we know the
dimensions of these spaces.
But now I'm asking you sort
of like the overlap between --
so the null space
and the row space,
those are in the same
n-dimensional space.
Those are -- well, those are
both subspaces of n-dimensional
space, and I'm basically
saying they can't overlap.
I can't have a vector like
this, a typical vector, that's
in the null space and it's
also a row of the matrix.
Why is that?
So that's a new sort of idea.
Let's just see
what it would mean.
I mean that A times this V,
why can this A times this
V it can't be zero.
Oh well, if it's
zero, so this is --
I'm getting it into
the null space here.
So this is -- now let's put
that vector's in the null space,
why can't the first row of
a matrix be one, two, three?
I can fill out the
matrix as I like.
Why is that impossible?
Well, you're seeing
it's impossible, right?
That if that was a row of the
matrix and in the null space,
that number would not be
zero, it would be fourteen.
Right.
So now we actually are beginning
to get a more complete picture
of these four subspaces.
The two that are over
in n-dimensional space,
they actually only
share the zero vector.
The intersection of the
null space and the row space
is only the zero vector.
And in fact the null space is
perpendicular to the row space.
That'll be the first
topic let's see,
we have a holiday Monday --
and I'll see you Wednesday
with perpendiculars.
And I'll see you Friday.
So good luck on the quiz.